I mean the thing about pain is that it
is just quite insistent it will not shut
up anyway my back hurts and good morning
it's Tuesday can we talk for a little
bit about the seductiveness of Despair
oh
it's easy for me to find despair
compelling first because it's simple
like as a world view it has this
reassuring if horrifying consistency
like you know life sucks Injustice is
everywhere and worsening not only are we
all going to die in time the Sun will
boil the oceans and every memory of what
we ever said or did or loved will
evaporate there's no need as Fitzgerald
once put it to hold and balance the
sense of the futility of effort with the
sense of the necessity to struggle
because there is only the futility of
effort all right let's go check on the
weather it's cold it's been cold forever
and it will never not be cold back to
you in the studio awesome well that
guy's bringing good energy to the party
then there's the fact that if you look
around seeking justification for despair
uh you will find it like how are we
supposed to respond except with despair
to the fact that 1.6 million people are
going to die of tuberculosis this year
not because we lack understanding of the
disease or treatments to cure it but
because of inequate Equitable access to
health care and impoverishment and other
forms of Injustice all right I'm going
to try standing and that's not even to
mention all of the like personal Horrors
right the feeling that I'm failing those
I love or that I'm a burden on them the
fear the grief despair addresses all of
this in a straightforward holistic way I
despair because despair is the correct
response to all this awfulness but as I
see it there are two big shortcomings to
this dead-sold hopelessness first it's
not helpful and second it's not true or
at least it's not the whole truth
despair is simple whereas Consciousness
is multitudinous mere despair won't
suffice in response to life because mere
anything won't suffice including mere
optimism or mere outrage right like the
idea that the eventual boiling of oceans
negates the work that we do together
implies that the lives of others are
meaningless just because they're
temporary and I just don't agree with
that the idea that I'm merely a a burden
implies that a person needing care makes
them less valuable which again I just
don't believe and the idea that the
world is hopeless because millions of
kids are going to die needlessly due to
impoverishment this year ignores the
fact that 30 years ago kids were twice
as likely to die before the age of five
and that change did not happen naturally
or inevitably it happened because many
people collaborated across time and
space they collaborated in anger and
frustration and disgust but not in
hopelessness I'm hiding behind the plant
I don't know why but this actually hurts
less than regular setting but the thing
is regressive change also involves lots
of organization and collaboration right
like the organized attempts to overturn
free and fair elections or to take away
the rights of the marginalized I'm not
saying that when we work together we
only change the world for the better I'm
saying that despair is the wrong
response to Consciousness because we are
going to change the world together and
we should be thoughtful about how we do
it destruction is often fast loud and
dramatic whereas reparative work tends
to be slow and quiet and unspectacular
but that's where the hope is for me and
I don't just mean in big projects like
building a maternity hospital in Sierra
Leone or working to expand voting rights
in the U.S I also mean in the quiet
human moments that we can give each
other last week my friend Chris called
me because he knew that I was in pain
and he said man I'm so sorry your back
hurts that sucks and then he listened to
me talk about it and he believed me and
that didn't really help with the pain
but it did help I just keep coming back
to that old Philip Larkin poem we must
be careful of each other we must be kind
while there is still time
Hank I'll see you on Friday